okay so let's talk about the
participants so
in this study there was 214
uh men and women uh 107 men 107 women
who had all been married less than one
year at the time of testing participants
were obtained from the public records of
marriage licenses issued within a large
County in the Midwest United States
traditionally conservative country I
think we would agree
um I don't know Midwest that probably
encompasses quite a few States but let's
just say that all couples who had been
married within the designated time
period were contacted by letter and
invited to participate in this study the
mean age of males average sorry the the
the the mean age of the male sample was
25.46 years so that's your average male
in the group The mean age of the female
sample do you guys remember mean medium
and mode the different average methods
taught in school I don't know if they
still do that anymore but it looks like
mean seems to be the default now they
use in these studies the mean age of
female sample was 24.78 so it looks like
the guys were about a year older than
the women couples were given 25 dollars
per couple in return for their
participation in the study which was
what is that
40 bucks in today's money with inflation
the way they're robbing us with
inflation I don't know you guys figure
that you you tell me in the comments
let's keep going though
um
so the abstracts materials and methods
participants procedure okay so let's do
the procedure next participants engage
in three separate episodes of assessment
as part of a large set of studies first
they received through the mail a battery
of instruments to be completed at home
in their spare time second participants
came to a lab testing session
approximately one week after receiving
the first sequence of mail questions
during the testing session spouses were
separated to preserve Independence and
to prevent contamination from contact or
discussion it was during this second
testing session that the participants
completed four instruments relevant to
the present report factors in choosing a
mate preferences concerning potential
mates
family and marital preferences
questionnaires and goals wanted in a
partner
third couple so the third round of
questions third couples were interviewed
towards the end of the second testing
session using a standard set of
interview questions to provide
information about the couple's
relationship and to give the
interviewers an opportunity to observe
participants so that they could provide
independent assessments of each other of
each participant's physical
attractiveness Face Body and overall
attractiveness confidence yeah now the
reason why they did this by the way
is because they use the most attractive
women in the study to determine what
beautiful women want
um so they're basically asking the guys
to rate the gals
makes sense right you want to know what
beautiful women want let's identify what
is objectively beautiful in this group
of 107 people and then we'll survey them
on their opinions
uh mate preference instruments should we
get into that basically it's on a rating
from zero to four
um and
well I mean I'll explain the scale in a
minute when I get to it but zero would
be irrelevant or unimportant and four
would be indispensable like it's a 100
must-have so essentially zero means
nothing or anything close to zero means
nothing and closer to four means it's
absolutely must-have there's there's
it's got to be there must have it
uh so we'll skip the instrument part
judgment physical attractiveness so they
would basically you know rate them uh
the face the body overall attractiveness
uh one through seven so they would
assign scores
uh mail results okay so the results here
so this is kind of the important stuff
um
so let's start so there's one two three
four different categories
now before I get to the categories
here's what I want to do in the live
chat actually I'm gonna do this as a
survey
I'm not gonna do the survey actually
we'll do this in a live chat like this
you guys tell me
what you think
in
actually there's too many categories for
me do it that way we're just gonna roll
with this follow me follow me here so
the good Gene indicators
physical genes you know symmetrical face
you know like muscularity uh Health cues
obviously you know
um those usually comes from things like
facial you know symmetry uh if you
weren't healthy growing up or you didn't
have a normal hormone profile you don't
get a symmetrical face you don't get a
structured jawline you don't get certain
things right
um so
the good Gene indicators were picked up
in this regard and the highest
I'll go highest from lowest okay we'll
do it that way the highest is sex appeal
so
does he look sexy does he look good
naked
it's right there looks matter okay so
that is the absolute highest with a
three okay
there's only one in this entire category
of survey results that got a four but
three is generally the highest so I'll
give you the the score so three with sex
appeal
0.28
so just beneath that so two eight uh
physically attractive
and then we go down to 0.23 physically
fit so not obese obviously V taper broad
shoulders narrow waist those are the
general cues that women look for for
good Gene indicators and then tied after
that with 0.2 is good looking and then
masculine
and the absolute last one which you'd
think would be higher based on if you
ask women their opinion is intelligence
with point one so according to the way
that they put the survey together
statistically insignificant
the next category was good investment
ability indicators
and again
I'll go from highest to lowest
uh 0.25 was the highest in this category
so
again not as high as 0.3 so 0.3 sex
appeal was the absolute highest so good
investment ability indicator
significantly lower at 0.25 sorry is
older than self-expressed in years
chicks dig older guys shocking right
um I've said this before usually
somewhere between
7 to 15 years age difference between uh
do it in a check especially for longer
term mating strategies it seems because
this is typically what these what these
surveys are trying to establish
um is more than reasonable
when you get into like the Leonardo
DiCaprio stuff where he's like pushing
50 and he's dating a 19 year old some
people say that gets a little bit weird
but hey if you can pull it off you know
how about it right because you can't
anyway so number one was older than self
right something that guys get shamed for
all the time which is what women are
mate selecting this is literally what
they're selecting in the survey the men
pick the most beautiful women then they
ask the most beautiful women what do you
want
they basically said I want everything
but they but there's a degree to how
much of everything they actually want
and older than self came right up at the
top a good investment ability after that
tied for second at 0.22 was good earning
capacity the ability to uh provide
and being a college graduate which is
interesting because they ranked
intelligence low but having a degree
higher than that in the next category so
they don't care if you're smart they
don't care if you're Street Smart that
doesn't matter to you but if you have a
piece of paper on the wall framed in
Mahogany with little letters after your
name that matters to women that's that's
attractive
probably because it ties into good
earning capacity that's that's probably
the default thinking that they would use
I would imagine you guys can chop it up
in the chat
uh so that was tied at 0.22 then next
below that at 0.19 was potential earned
income expressed in dollars
uh so good earning capacity so having
the ability to earn ranks higher than
potential income capacity
so that's
pretty much in line you know with what
I've talked about
below that next is 0.14 so now we're
approaching statistically insignificant
um is favorable social status or rating
so status
doesn't matter as much as as earning
potential or being older
interesting and then last in this
category for good investment ability
indicators at 0.13 is ambition and
industriousness
uh next after this we're in the
hypothesized good parenting indicators
and the apps so the highest score in
this entire survey meaning it is
absolutely desirable and must be in
place again this is for longer term
mating of course is desire for home and
children at point four
it's a perfect score
below that at 0.3 which is still very
significant is emotional stability and
maturity
beneath that is 0.28 raising children
well with gold priorities
beneath that at 0.24 likes children
0.23 is fond of children
and right at the very bottom
statistically insignificant again at
0.12 is being kind and understanding
being kind and understanding ranks at
0.12 whereas being
sexy having sex appeal is 0.3
so you can so all of that that
you know you hear women say all the time
when they're surveyed well what kind of
guy do you like and you know they're on
the street and she's like well I want a
guy that's kind and understanding and
he's got to be funny and you know they
start to go from there but kind of but
kind always seems to pop up very high
when you ask women their opinion
publicly where they might be judged or
critic or or critiqued for their opinion
I mean you know if you ask a woman on
the street the average woman anyway
that's not a 304 hasn't only fans or
anything like that but the average woman
you know
um what's important they're not going to
blurt out sex appeal which is very very
high on the ranking list
right
but anyway kindness understanding always
always comes in first so here's the next
section hypothesize hypothesized say
that word properly good partner
indicators there's three in this
category the highest ranked at 0.24
being a loving partner
0.14 is devotion
which is pretty close to statistically
insignificant and right at the very
bottom the absolute lowest rank in this
entire survey
uh next to intelligence which was ranked
.10
.11
loyalty
so
what we've heard and I put this in the
description of the video
excuse me what we've heard from women is
they want loyal men that are kind and
understanding
and are intelligent
and they rank those three things the
absolute lowest
a lot of quote unquote nice guys out
there
well you know often say I'm a nice guy
I'm intelligent
I'm kind I'm understanding and I'm super
loyal to a woman
and lo and behold
women
doesn't matter to them it's
statistically insignificant to them if
you're kind understanding loyal or
intelligent if you have a piece of paper
on the wall That's framed in Mahogany
with little letters after your name
that's good you could be dumb as
but you could have a degree and that's
good for them but real intelligence
doesn't really matter
of course having money that matters
having earned a potential that matters
so why intelligence is not tied into
earning potential is interesting because
they should correlate
shouldn't they wouldn't you think so I
don't know you guys tell me in the chat
here
so that's it that's it the most
important indicators to women are
desire for home and children
sex appeal being physically attractive
and masculine
those are the main things
being being uh being a hot guy that has
the ability to make money that's it
earning potential ranked up high there
and again loyalty kind understanding
intelligence doesn't matter
anyway there's loads and loads and loads
and loads of uh cited references in this
again I'm going to put it in the
description the video once I get off the
uh the show at the end of it and you
guys you know can drill down to it but
references and cross-references they're
listed in here going back as far as
there's 1986 from one of their studies
1970s this guy's been doing this for
decades David Buss has been doing this
for ages he's he's a dinosaur in this
space
he's got lots and lots of stuff in here
um I might at one point I mean if you
guys are interested you know you can
tell me in the the comments go through
some of these other ones as well because
they're all intertwined and interlinked
in different ways and
yeah I just I just find this you know
this stuff interesting because it's like
you know you go around it's like oh just
be a nice guy just be yourself you know
um
be her friend you know like what do we
all hear you know growing up buyer
flowers
open the door for her you know be kind
be understanding
kindness is rank be loyal to her loyalty
doesn't even matter these are married
women that took the survey and loyalty
was statistically insignificant to them
it was more important that you were
sexy hot masculine
earned money had a future potential to
earn money had some kind of degree on
the wall
those things were way more important
than loyalty which is interesting
because you know you have all these guys
going around they just get so pissed off
like I'm just a nice guy and I'm loyal
it's like well
the ladies have spoken I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out